all right so I teased this story earlier
and I think it's a really important one
because it is exactly the type of
deception and stochastic terrorism quite
frankly that will lead to real world
violence the headline that started
floating around is Democrats have
started killing Republicans Democrats
are just murdering Republicans and the
questions are where did that come from
and where is this supposedly happening
well where it came from is a republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green
speaking at the Trump rally in war in
Michigan over the weekend uh Daily Beast
covered it many media Outlets covered it
and the headlines are something like
Marjorie Taylor green says Democrats
have started killings of Republicans
let's listen to what she had to say and
as is often the case actually should I
explain now let's let's play it first
let's just play it and then there's
plenty to talk about here
we're all Targets now though for daring
to push back against the regime and it
doesn't stop at a weaponized legal
system by the way use of the word regime
to suggest that the Biden Administration
is anything other than a democratically
elected presidency
[Music]
girl boy was run down by a Democrat
driver who confessed to killing the
teenager simply because he was a
republican that's not true and I'll tell
you about it later
[Music]
even right here in Michigan just last
week an 83 year old woman was shot in
the back for advocating for The Unborn
that is also not true and I will tell
you about that story in a minute
[Music]
yeah Joe Biden has declared every
freedom loving American and Enemy of the
State but under Republicans we will take
back our country from the Communists who
have stolen it and want us to disappear
we will expose the unelected bureaucrats
the real enemies within who have abused
their power and declared political
Warfare all right so first of all there
there are no Communists that have taken
over Joe Biden's not a communist the
Communists and the Socialists really
don't like Biden because they say he's
basically just the Centrist of
Republican light capitalist okay so
there's no Communists here that's just
nonsense the rhetoric that Marjorie
Taylor green is using there is
completely unacceptable and it is very
dangerous because the lunatics in the
audience will hear it and they'll
believe it and then they might go go and
say well listen if the Democrats are
just killing Republicans on site then we
can do the same but understand that the
stories that Marjorie Taylor green told
aren't true she says a Democrat ran over
a republican because he was a republican
just ran him over with his car
what happened and you can Google the
story two morons more than likely got
into a political argument we don't know
whether alcohol or substances were a
factor but two people got into an
argument
it was an argument about politics the
argument escalated and one of them
jumped in his car and hit the other
person with his car
it was a Democrat who hit a republican
it's wrong it's a crime political
discussion should never escalate to that
should be charged should be punished if
convicted but Marjorie Taylor green
wants you to think some guy just drove
by someone with a Maga hat that he
didn't know and ran him over like it's
just some kind of Street assassination
this was a an argument that became a
fight that went crazy crimes were
committed punished the criminals but
it's not my neighbor's a Democrat I'm
gonna go run him over it didn't happen
Okay then she says an 83 year old woman
was shot for advocating for The Unborn
it's not what happened Okay Google the
story a man in Michigan was charged for
shooting an elderly woman in an
altercation that involved an accidental
shooting Richard Harvey is 74 years old
the story as far as we know right now is
that Joan Jacobson was campaigning
door-to-door in Michigan against
abortion that part is true
um Joan Jacobson came to the door of the
Harveys Harvey and his wife were arguing
they'd had a disagreement with the woman
who was going door-to-door arguing
against abortion
um and then at a certain point the guy
grabbed his uh what what are the details
here grabbed his uh rifle a 22 grabbed a
22. uh the rifle belonged to the guy's
wife and said hey you got to get out of
here you got to get out of here and
fired a warning shot at a tree now I
it's already wrong I'm already
completely against it okay then he says
that he quote without thinking tried to
hit the woman's clipboard out of her
hands with the rifle and at that point
he accidentally shot the woman so
negligent discharge should be charged
with a crime if the investigation
determines one was committed as I always
say but it was not a story The Way
Marjorie Taylor green paints it is there
was a pro-life event and a guy showed up
with a rifle and shot a pro-life
protester this was another one of these
alter K altercation confrontation things
I'm not defending them them but they are
not the lurid assassinations I mean that
that uh Marjorie Taylor green claims
them to be Trump does this a lot during
his speeches
Trump will still tell stories like
uh we we just saw the conviction of an
illegal immigrant who was released into
the public and shot someone dead right
and then you look up the story and the
crime happened when Trump was President
yes now they were convicted but what
does it matter the crime happened when
Trump was President trying to make the
point that under Biden these things are
happening even though it happened under
Trump in some of these cases look up
every one of these and of course
extraordinarily dangerous because when
people on the right hear these stories
they become more likely on average to
act out in violent ways because they
believe that the left is doing it
extraordinarily dangerous stuff one of
our sponsors is all form the easiest way
to design your own custom sofa I have
one from all form unlike other companies
all form lets you choose the fabric the
size the shape color even the color of
the legs I have not one but two all
forms so office I've had them for years
they look good as new definitely the
most comfortable Furniture I own and it
gets even cooler because all form sofas
are completely modular you can buy a
sofa and if you move you can adapt it to
the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical Sofa Company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and arm chairs everything
is made in the USA using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy I didn't even
need any tools which is good because I
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund right now all form is giving
my audience 20 off all orders at
allform.com Pacman the link is down
below